at least six six thirty
um we are streaming live now uh can I
welcome uh all the members and officers
who've come to attend this meeting
um
if I go through the agenda now
item one is
attendances and we've got I I've got uh
councilor Rose Thompson and councilor
Denise Weston is there any other
apologies that have been given apologies
have also been received from Council
right
yeah thanks thanks for that
item two is the minutes of the previous
meeting
which was held on the 11th of January
can we agree these as a true and correct
record
okay
um item three decorations of Interest
has any member got any interest in the
uh this the the items on the agenda
you know
item four question from the public we
haven't had any
uh item five is the investment
management strategy and that report has
been circulated
um and is it you Richard or oh oh yes
Tom
yes uh right counselor Ross thank you
very much Chad I'm obviously here in
place of councilor Patel for this item
but just looking at the um the dates of
your scrutiny meetings for the Erp to
all but one of them this Municipal year
so I very much see myself as a member of
this committee because it feels like it
but it's lovely to be back once again at
scrutiny um you'll see that we've put
together one of our team has put
together a a brief report on the
investment uh strategy I'm hoping it was
quite clear I I kind of read it I
thought actually this is probably one of
the best reports I've seen that explains
the investment um strategy and how we
work as a board and what changes have
been made over the course of the the
last few years with the strategy and
you'll have also seen it attached to
that agenda item the the latest
investment strategy which was also
available via the budget papers so in
February 2020
um we increased the fund to 500 million
pounds we don't have any we don't have
commitment up to that point our current
commitment is around 330 million pounds
which gives us a little bit of breathing
space should we identify any other
opportunities in terms of the strategy
itself it's closely aligned to our
corporate priorities
um you'll remember we had a fair tax
declaration a couple of years ago now
which we looked we comply with within
this strategy for you know Investments
since that Declaration was made and very
much our emphasis on the strategy is to
look at things within Trafford and the
next store near Regions and look at
regeneration opportunities as well the
board as you'll be aware is a
cross-party board and we have advisors
in the form of CBRE
um they are very good at filtering out
stuff that we don't think we'd um we
we'd approve if something came to the
board it would um it would go through an
initial Improvement um sorry initial
approval stage subject to due diligence
it would then come back to us after the
due diligence and then we'd make a
decision cross party
um on that particular investment the
final thing that I'd like to draw
attention to is is obviously there is a
variance in this year's budget it's
currently is budget of just over 2
million pounds that's where we've
um not met or identified Investments or
some have come to an early conclusion or
been paid off
um but we it has contributed over four
million pounds to this current Year's
budget so and over the course of the
last five years has been a a significant
number of um of of of of gains from
having that strategy in place so with
that I'm sure Richard and I are very
happy to take any questions
all right thank you for that
um introduction
um yeah councilor Proctor yeah thank you
chair
um yeah it's clearly been a very
successful scheme I remember the time
when it was mooted originally I think
the 2017 Round Rock then and there was a
lot of concerns whether it would
actually be successful it's been a
massive success this scheme and brought
great benefit to the borough really in
terms of the support the revenue budget
and then sir 23 million which is
fantastic plus the add-on economic
benefits of those Investments are buying
Trafford
um
my question was though in terms of I
mean the majority of the the schemes are
in Trafford or going to mention there's
one or two outside that is there a
greater level of due diligence in those
other schemes because it seems to me
there are potentially more risk than the
ones in Trafford or you know in Greater
Manchester is there a greater level of
diligence on those those schemes
Joe that's a a very good question and we
have steered away from
um things further revealed Beyond
Trafford and under the immediate
neighbors I don't know whether we do
have a greater due diligence I mean
we've not really had anything come
through I'm just looking at Richard to
uh to clarify here
I think
yeah as the leader said
um the the approach within the strategy
has changed from uh as it originally set
out in 1718 so some of those properties
that we acquired uh outside of the
borough were not things that we would do
now in the given the strategy that we've
got um at the moment so we are very much
focused on Trafford great to Manchester
because we're operating within an
economic region the Regeneration
benefits come because of where the
business rates retention work that uh we
operate within that Geo footprint
um
I wouldn't say that we do any greater
due diligence out outside of the the
borough other than to about the the kind
of natural intelligence so that there's
a local intelligence that we have on
things that are going in the borough
about the way that the borough Market
operates so we don't necessarily have so
we try and do a little bit more about
that on the market intelligence but most
of our due diligence is around risk
we're looking at risk and what are the
security in our mid to get a risk and
that that security and that mitigation
is very much the same whether it's in
Borough within GM or out of out of
borough and it's all around property
related risks we're very clear on the
investment strategy we're invested into
property they're indirect and our risk
resource our risks are managed and
mitigated to the security that we have
against the property value on the
property and that applies wherever it
may be
that was kind of the logic of a question
really in terms of because you've got
that local knowledge and certainly
Trafford and only potentially in Greater
Manchester as well so you haven't got
that in other
uh Investments so yeah that makes sense
thank you
um Council Winston Stanley
uh thank you chair first to our other
remarks made by Council Proctor in terms
of the success of this scheme and also
the fact that it's concentrating
investments in Trafford and as close to
travel as we can get within greater
Manchester and my question is really
around the the risk Reserve which we've
used this year to make up some of the
shortfall now I know in the
conversations we've had in the scrutiny
meetings we've had in terms of the uh
what we might call the day-to-day
budgets of the council we're very
concerned the risk Reserve doesn't fall
below what you might call it a uh well a
risky level at what level would we
consider the risk Reserve here
below which would we get concerned or I
misunderstood the definition of the risk
Reserve in the capital budget
thank you I'm going to give you a a
general Assurance first of all before I
might pass over to someone who may know
what level we'd go to where we'd start
to have concerns about I think in terms
of the risk reserve it is in a healthy
position we are
um
conservative of small City in terms of
what we we put more I think we put
sufficient in there and then some to
protect us from any exposure in terms of
any of our investments and I know in
previous years or not this year that it
has gone up in value as the years gone
on
um we do use it we do use it as a kind
of short-term thing from time to time if
we if we need to um to to me to short
for which will then come back in when we
look at um future investment
opportunities but I don't know in terms
of the the calculation of what our floor
limit is for that
um I know Graham's not in the room but I
wonder if uh in his place does Richard
know what kind of floor limit would be
looking at I think it there is reserve
on the investment strategy operates
slightly different to the other General
reserves that we have and the the kind
of general fund um Reserve because the
risks are in some ways easier to
quantify because they're risk related to
specific properties and we can see the
properties and we can calculate the
risks on those properties so we don't
have a specific floor we haven't set a
specific floor on that it is something
that we review in relation to the
properties that we're holding on our
view of the relative risk of those
um we've got
and if you look at what we've got you've
got the property Acquisitions things
like sonova house and
um at Sainsbury's in altering where
we're getting a rental income against
the stream so we can see what the risk
of that is against the lease we've got
other Investments such as Castle oh well
we're investing we're providing
development loans to support a
development and similar with network
space in Broad Heath where your risk
changes over time during the development
cycle and your risk increases your
amount of debt goes up as the property
is being built and then your risk starts
to reduce as properties are sold and
your development gets to a certain
you've got more cost certainty so we
kind of try and keep an eye on where we
are within those relative risks and that
then sets where the floor may be so it's
not a specific we need x million it's
what do we perceive as being our risk at
the moment across all of the investment
strategy I think the penny might just
drop it so it's not an actual pot of
money is it it's a it is a pot of money
no it is a part of money so so on
um when we work out the investment
return so we provide we provide uh
either we're getting a rental income
stream which is what we're getting for
sun over house or and from uh Grafton
Center and others oh we're getting a
margin on a loan that we're providing
which is what we do on a development bit
of that income that we get back in
there's an element that we put into MRP
so that's minimum Revenue position
provision so that's what we use to pay
off debts that's the amount that might
get saved up and ultimately goes against
it gets paid off the debt
there's amount that then goes into the
risk reserves this is actual cash coming
from the income that we're getting so as
risk Reserve builds up an actual cash
amount and then the balance is the
income that we get so the income that we
get is the last bit having done the MRP
and the risk the risk Reserve so it's an
actual pot of if you like it is an
actual pot of cash which is why we've
got the ability to then to use and to to
change
it's not just an encounting thing I've
said that as the non-accountant in the
room by the way and if Graham's watching
at home kicking me virtually under the
table then we will clarify should we
both apologize soon I always apologize
in advance in these things man thanks
thank you thank you
thank you Chad um I'll ask three
questions if I may um but you might want
to check Graham's safe for that cash um
so first two questions are relating to
property of development so the bulk of
the net income that we generate between
this program is in property development
so a couple of questions around that one
how do we do more of it if it's so
successful and to
is there any way we can Benchmark
traffic's performance in this area
against other 3M authorities
and the third a broader question and
seeing whether we can try and align this
at all with our commitment and focus on
addressing the climate crisis might
there have been opportunities to look
for investment opportunities relating to
some of our priorities around the
climate crisis off the top of my head
thinking about clean our generation
that's cleaner clean energy generation
or possibly any of the investment
potential in the Trafford Park green
plan thank you
thank you very much
um in terms of how do we do more
we we we we we consider we've obviously
got that capacity within that 500
million pound pocket and you'll you'll
have seen that we're we're committed to
just over 332 or just shy of 333 million
pounds of that so far
we look at viable opportunities so every
time a viable opportunity comes along
that passes the initial test of our
advisors CBRE and then goes through the
you know the discussion at Investment
Management board that is the way that we
identify things so we don't we take that
cautious approach
um and we'll continue to take that
cautious approach but we we do we are
open and receptive to anything that
comes through to us at that stage of the
investment management board but it's
gone through a few things before it gets
to us because we want to make sure
things are as watertight as possible if
we're considering Investments I think
benchmarking against GM that's an
interesting one we don't do that at the
moment
um I think what would be even more
interesting is to Benchmark against
those local authorities that have got
into trouble about this because there is
a lot of news coverage about a couple of
local authorities not near here that
have been in trouble in the past we've
looked at you know what what lessons we
can draw from that unfortunately we
aren't doing any of the things that um
that those but I'm sure if um if we're
able to we can kind of share that that
analysis with you when comparing with
with places that have um have fallen
foul of strategies for not following
proper due diligence and and regard for
caution the other thing about the
climate crisis yes absolutely we we are
very very very keen to look at
opportunities to invest in things that
will address the climate crisis
particularly locally we have to balance
that with viability and risk to the
council though so yeah we are very much
open to that we want to see that as a as
a board but we also need to balance that
with the um with the risk approach that
we take as well so yeah definitely open
well I don't know if Rich wants to add
anything
thank you just to add to that um and
those three questions so um we are
really keen and up looking for other
opportunities to invest in in Borough we
also have a lot of contact with
developers through the planning system
and other parts of the of the place
Direction particular so we take that as
an opportunity to talk to uh developers
where there may be a funding opportunity
and we are operating within a commercial
environment yes there are lots of other
people providing development Finance
whereby nowhere the the only people
um uh in the game
and we have to comply with I'm going to
say stated it's not called stated
anymore but in old fashioned so we have
to comply with with stated
um stated rules so where we have to be
Market competitive in what we're doing
we can't undercut the market uh
specifically so there's a there's a kind
of position there where we need to take
uh as the leader said we've got a very
clear position about risk and where we
sit on the risk curve what we'll accept
as risk and that's set out in our asset
investment strategy so we're very open
with people and that in the public so
well we'll look at along to value and
loan to cost
and that means this is there are certain
developments that we wouldn't want to be
involved in because they don't meet our
risk requirements and and we only
provide first charge debt so we don't do
medicine in debt or bridging debt or
anything like that we're very clear we
just do first charge secured against the
property
um I think it's difficult to compare
against other GM authorities because
everyone has a slightly different
approach about how they do this the
government rules have changed so they've
got some things that may be kind of
altered and historical when you had more
scope to buy properties to get a rental
income stream that's where we started on
our investment strategy in the
government the guidance changed away
from that so I think it is quite uh
difficult to compare and also the extent
to which regeneration schemes that you
might be willing to take a loss or take
a longer term View and put an effective
list on patient Equity because you get
the benefits down the line and and
sometimes that benefit isn't in a direct
investment return if that benefit might
be in future council tax uh receipts or
future business receipts so it's not we
look in here in this this paper very
clearly on what our direct investment
return is we're not accounting because
that gets dealt with definitely actually
but we're supporting quite a lot of
council tax and business rates that
ultimately come through to the local
Authority as well that we that we
benefit from
um and on the final bit around climate
change and carbon neutral that is
something we amended our investment
strategy in 2019 part of that change was
to align it more closely with our
corporate priorities in particular
around climate change and cabin neutral
we do speak to CBRE as our investment
advisors on a regular basis around
opportunities on that we try and do that
in two ways so one is when we are
looking at investing in schemes can we
use the fact that we're providing loan
Finance to push them a little bit more
about what the carbon cost of that
development can we push them to be a bit
more carbon neutral and by the time
sometimes by the time we get involved
because we're very clear we want to keep
a separation between this and planning
decisions we're a bit late in the day we
can't necessarily get those changes but
we do start we do certainly encourage
that and all the reports that go through
to investment board set out what the
carbon credentials of that development
is so it is a factor something that gets
taken into account in the decision in
the decision making process yeah we will
look for other opportunities if there
are opportunities around uh
generation carbon cutting anything like
that then that is definitely something
that we're interested in bearing in mind
the overall Rider still of it's got to
be property related so we're not going
to invest in a solar farm through this
would be my view because it's not
directly property related we might
provide loan Finance for someone to
develop a solar farm because we can then
link that to the property so if you get
the difference between where we're doing
that so that's the approach that we're
trying to take and it needs to sit in
the same position on the risk curve and
it still needs to generate a financial
return to the authority so it's part of
it it's absolutely in there we do look
for opportunities we've got lots of work
around District 8 Network that we're
doing the Trafford part work that you
talked about so absolutely very scope
for us to invest that's in line with our
strategy then we are very very keen to
do that the administration is and the
investment management board are very
keen that we do that as well
thanks very much and I think in previous
group news we've delved even further
into risk and some of the more problem
problematic Council experiences so I
feel reassured thank you
Council of Coggins
[Music]
thank you um I think actually my
question which was about the risk
Reserve has been answered but I wanted
to well chip in a couple of elements one
thing I did early when I was getting my
head around this years ago was um do
some sip for training on this very
subject which is really useful
um I think Judith Lloyd came with me we
were about on the accounts in order at
the time and um what I did was give you
the tools to analyze and compare the
differences between what we're doing and
what some of the ones that have gotten
into trouble did
um and so on so I do recommend that for
you know I think the more of us who
understand what's going on and are able
to
um be a critical friend of the system
um the better
um and uh you know Echo the comments
we've heard about it being a successful
scheming that has brought in a lot of
money but just to remind us all of
course that this isn't really the job of
a local Council to be a property
developer or to be a a lending vehicle
for for property developers and that
really well we should be getting back to
ideally is a government that funds us
properly so we're not reliant on all
these schemes so while it is successful
um and I can see that we absolutely need
it at the moment
um I suppose in an Ideal World we would
not need it
absolutely two very important points
that I mean around training you write
and when you look at reports of local
authorities that have for one reason or
another not just connected to
um investment management but to finance
in general where they've where they've
got into trouble is because there hasn't
been enough challenge or understanding
around what's going on so there's all of
us are on a training learning you know
development approach Journey yeah I know
there's more training that I can do I'm
sure it's the same for everyone in this
room so I think that's a very good point
about the Sip for training and yes
indeed in terms of in an Ideal World we
we would be getting greater funding from
the the the government we're a very very
lean Council I won't rehash the budget
discussions
um but the good thing that we do do with
this strategy is look at regeneration
um and we've do some really good stuff
around regenerate racing work with
strategy which you know we've got lots
of potential to do more of that in the
future and which is what I'd like to see
yeah I think just to I think I think
it's very clear when you read our
strategy now income generation is
important because we need to manage the
risk but this is the focuses about
regeneration so a lot of the work that
we've done is around regeneration so
things we've done in Stratford in
altering um the broad 8th uh screen
network spur scheme which is was uh on
the site of a property where the
business ad unfortunately uh uh Gone
bust this is a new development bringing
new jobs back into the back into that
location
um so that is certainly what we're
trying to focus as much as we can in a
greater focus on being in Trafford as a
starting point for our investment
counselor one
thanks chair
um I know we've worked with um CBRE from
for many many years I just wondered do
we ever
um look at that company and compare them
to others would we get different advice
better advice from somebody else
we're out to Tender at the moment for uh
investment advisor I think that answers
that question
um
I'm interested in in Social
um investment and we've not quite worked
out the policy yet but we're going to
talk to community groups
uh reading the paper
can anybody give me some more details
about that
I think it
it comes back in some point to council
Carter's Point Lincoln in with carbon
neutral uh it's how what's the other
opportunities that we can do out of the
investment to generate a greater benefit
of and above the kind of the the built
environment regeneration benefits I
don't think we have an answer as to what
that looks like as yet it is is more
just some kind of thinking about how do
we maximize the overall return from the
investment so we're not looking at it
entirely in it just purely from a
financial perspective recognizing that
we're managing the risk so it's it's
it's a kind of exploration rather than a
an answer at the moment
presumably we're going to harness the
expertise of the community groups which
I know we're all involved in so I'm sure
they've got lots of knowledge to to
share with us so very supportive of that
scheme
um just finally how does our sort of 500
million compared to similar Authority so
we always compare ourselves to Stockport
are they got a pool of money similar
similar to us
uh I don't think they've got an asset
investment strategy that works in the
same way that ours does so I think I
think it's difficult to compare so they
do some similar things if you look at
the mayoral Development Corporation that
they've got in Stockport at the moment
that's driving an awful lot of the new
generation that's going on around the
train station that's similar it's a
different structure but it's very
similar to the work that we're doing at
Lumina Village and in in Stratford and
with with bruntwood but I don't think
for them and I'm not close enough I
don't think for them it sits necessarily
within a an asset investment strategy it
operates quite the same way that ours
does
um it sits within the kind of General
budget so there are similar activity but
we approach it in a different in a
different way to I don't think the many
other authorities certainly I'm aware of
that of an asset investment strategy and
an IMB that works like ours does
yeah
I know we've been looking at the risk
Reserve side of things is there such a
risk register of that you've been using
of some kind within this the investment
strategy that uh
yeah there's there's an overall it kind
of sits within the council's overall
risk register but we've got a we have a
risk uh plan that we do for each
investment so every part that we take
through our investment management uh
pardon Council against the former
representative on that and uh Council
Ross can can confirm there's a risk
assessment as part of that so we'll look
at a range of of what the mitigation is
against the risk because it's not in
this no because that's that is
commercially sensitive because it's
related to to those specific
developments so the approach which I'd
say we're very aware that this is public
money and there's public scrutiny so at
the point when we are going through uh
determining uh an investment then that
is dealt with commercially sensitive in
the terms of that and everything also
Investment Management board and that
that is all confidential at the point on
which a facility is agreed and signed up
and everything's done then we publish us
as in this report and so it and through
budget reports through the year what
we've invested in how much we've
invested what our return is so we're
very open about that after the decision
is made but the risk register itself is
commercially sensitive related to that
individual property because it looks at
what their contract is what their record
is what our security is uh what the
market assessment is so there's a lot of
information there that is not something
that we because of the commerciality
that we can put to the public domain
okay
um just around around this up
um I I do think it's an excellent report
and I think you know it's quite detailed
um and it explains things really well
and I think that's something that we we
like to see in scrutiny something that
he is explainable and uh and useful for
us to you know
um sort of look at all the risks and and
how it's actually going and I think
there's there has to be a lot of
monitoring clearly in relation to this
but it you know it is reassuring that we
we minimize the the risk in the way that
we are doing but that has to be kept you
know on on the a lot of scrutiny in in
in my view the bottom line is that it
has been as other members have said it
has been very successful
um and when when you you know they have
have figures over the five-year period
that have been doing this and
um you know it's nearly 30 million
pounds that have been brought
uh into this Council to support
you know the revenue budget and
therefore support the services that we
provide
um but I think for for the committee
it's really helpful to
to bring this kind of report
periodically
um you know throughout the the year or
you know the
um
not necessarily every meeting but I
think maybe twice a year
um just to see how it's performing I
know there are other committees that
actually look at the risks and and look
at
um and monitor uh the the the situation
but I think we as a scrutiny committee
probably need that you know on fit
periodically
I mean I think obviously audit committee
have got a role in terms of uh
scrutinizing on on risk and I know
there's been previous reports to audit
committee on the risk and on the risk
position uh I think I'll probably not
giving too much away about the budget
for 24.25 but I'll be surprised if we
didn't have an element of asset
investment strategy in that in that
budget so I know that we'll be coming
back talking to uh scrutiny during the
the budget review uh process again
um at the back end of of this year when
we're looking at the 24 25 budget I
think other than that I think we're very
happy to to come to scrutiny we do
recognize that this is a significant
piece of work with the authority does
there's a lot of recipes a lot of
regeneration outcomes uh that arise from
that and I think that this report in
particular is focused around risks that
came out of conversation at budget
scrutiny and the ability for us to to
hit the Six Million Pound Target I think
we're very happy to come back at a point
in time where we can talk about some of
the outputs that we've delivered through
this housing jobs uh other investment
that that comes I think would be more
than happy to to do that and just credit
to Frank Fallon in the finance team for
for producing um the report because he
did a very good job on it so our credit
to him
just wanted to Echo that and say yeah no
there is definitely a role for the
scrutiny committee and is given the
quality of the questions that we've got
it's an important check on the process
from my perspective so yes happy
obviously it's not me normally that does
this but to speak on behalf of the
executive member that would come back
and and give you updates
and Richard can I thank you for coming
along uh I know that you need to get off
now so we'll make you stay for all of
the meeting so thanks very much though
for your input
very helpful
right
can we now move on to item
six corporate plan delivery I think it's
over to you councilor Ross
we know that you're not very busy
thank you very much chair
um yes I'm delighted to present this in
my relatively new role as leader of the
council you'll have seen the
presentation that was circulated with
the papers I'm not going to speak to the
presentation I'm going to presume that
you've you've read it I will pull out a
few key things though and then be happy
to take any questions away so in terms
of the performance indicators that we
have there are 57 in total and they're
kind of bunched into our corporate
strategic priorities so we've got
reducing Health inequalities supporting
people out of poverty and addressing our
climate crisis and then also got the
council wide measures that we have in
place some of them are annual
some of the quarterly so out of the 57
that we've got uh
23 are annual indicators the remaining
are quarterly indicators and if you've
got time and I always recommend this
please do go to Trafford data lab
they've got a great dashboard on where
we're up to with our corporate
priorities
looking at the um looking at the
performance indicators uh on a quarterly
basis you'll have seen that our last
report was tacked onto the budget
monetary report that went to screw sorry
went to executive and in um in January
um and in terms of the Reds ambers and
greens on that report seven in total
were read eight were Amber and
17 were were green the remainder are
either annual you know annual measures
um or no target was set and I'm just
going to pull out an example of a red an
example of an Amber and an example of a
green before I am happy to take
questions so so one example of a a red
rating was the improve the percentage of
primary school children achieving the
expected standards in Reading Writing
and maths at key stage two this is
currently below Target our Target is 77
at the moment we're looking at 66.9
percent
um it was expected that this level would
drop and part of that is due to the
restricted attendance at school during
the uh pandemic
um we'll still remain one of the higher
levels of attainment in the country but
obviously we're looking at that figure
we're monitoring it closely and as the
we come out of the the pandemic period
um we'd be looking to um to color that
back in the future but it just goes to
show how important it is that we keep an
eye on our children's education after
they've been through considerable
disruption with understandable reasons
with the um with with the lockdown
various lockdowns um in terms of a an
example of a an Amber
um status
um
improve the number of people being
rehoused um from Trafford housing
waiting list I'm sure colleagues will
all be very much aware of the pressures
of housing in this Borough there are
thousands of people waiting to be
rehoused in this Borough and only a
small supply of available properties
it's not it's a new thing it's been it's
been a situation for years which is why
we're very keen to to look at building
more properties so that people can can
live in the borough so for this one
um the number of people being rehoused
was 69 in quarter to 164 on the year the
good news is we are on track
um for for meeting that Target by the
end of this year but as I say the
challenges that we face is that the
supply of housing is just very very
limited if ever you go on traffic Home
Choice or have the chance to speak to
our colleagues in housing options you
will see how many people are chasing
after how you know so so so many few
properties um available so it's it's
going to need some long-term Solutions
but actually in terms of the the measure
we put in place we are on track to meet
that by the end of this year and finally
in terms of a green status
um improve the number of affordable
housing completion so that kind of links
into the the the the previous points I
made but we've had a successful quarter
of housing completions which has
exceeded the the targets
um affordable completions this quarter
um that we assessed are 75 units as part
of sail west 31 appointments at uh
higher Road in urmston 15 apartments at
Chapel house uh in Altrincham 16 houses
Oak Road Partington six affordable units
on at T farm development in Partington
and six affordable units at the Lock
Lane development in Partington so that
is an example of where we're exceeding
that's one very pleasing to me given the
the the ongoing precautions that we have
with regards to local housing provision
and affordable housing so yeah hopefully
the rest of the slides were very um very
self-explanatory very informative for
you I'm happy to take any questions
thank you any questions
right Council Oxford
uh yeah it's got a few really
um on the health
um ones
um I was just
see that looking at the stats it says
that uh the level of depression is
increased which looks quite worrying
Trend
um and I was also thinking about on the
stopping smoking
um that you're you've put on there and I
think it's really important that we look
at cannabis use because I'm aware that's
been openly smoked
a lot of public places now and you know
I feel that has an impact on other
people as well as the users
in terms of the environmental stuff I
wonder about your home better and what
the app whether you've got any evidence
of the uptake on that at all
um
and I see on this stats that they look
like looks like recycling is decreasing
in in Trafford
um maybe I'll look and read it wrong
um another thing I wanted to ask about
was you talk about supporting libraries
I wondered what that what actually you
were doing in library to support people
okay
thank you um quite a few questions there
and unfortunate that Simon's at the end
of the table for the
for the library one
um in terms of the recycling I I thought
actually that that was a a good news
story was obviously always scope for us
to do more but um rates have improved in
you know in our last um in our last
monetary report in terms of the the
smoking I I agree with you about the uh
the smell of uh of people smoking
cannabis I I I think it's unpleasant I
think it does have impacts on other
people and um yeah I think it should be
something that we do consider as part of
the the smoking cessation
um before I get to libraries what was
the other one that you wanted to raise
we'll take that away and and get you
some information on that because I think
that is a good point and we'll see what
we can find out and Simon would you like
to uh elaborate on on helping libraries
apologies I haven't actually seen the
presentation that you've got in front of
me but the I'm assuming that the help in
libraries is around the Digital support
that that we're particularly focusing on
which
is
we know a demand more and more of life
is online so all of the Frontline staff
within libraries are being
um
have been trained and are having extra
kind of development and building their
confidence about how they sit next to
somebody and help that person to either
get online or or undertake new things
online and to be safe online as well so
that's the that's the service that is
being offered within libraries um
so you so yeah so that's fine I wasn't
it wasn't really clear on the
presentation so if that's mostly around
digital access yeah
okay uh counselor fast
thank you
um thanks so just looking at this um and
again focusing on the first priority
here the health inequalities I wondered
if you could perhaps uh forgive me if
it's missed in one of the 57 but in the
report I couldn't see anything on how
air pollution factors into that first
priority so obviously we know that
higher levels of air pollution are going
to be associated with health issues like
exhaust spacing asthma and potentially
leading to things like heart lung
diseases Etc I last looked at the air
pollution monitor sites a few years ago
but I didn't think we had that many in
the south of the borough so I just
wonder if you could reflect on how that
hinders our ability to properly measure
Health inequality if we take air
pollution into account
okay that's good the um it actually
comes under
um looking at that I'm just looking at
the main report here it comes under
addressing our climate price uh crisis
so the reduction on your mean
concentration of particulate uh matter
um looking at the sites we've got Moss
Park the a56 in wellacre so I think the
may we will check what's the provision
is in the south of the borough as as you
well know from last Council I I grew up
in timpley I had asthma as a child I
think it was you know possibly related
to the you know simply area you know it
is something that we uh we should
explore in terms of making sure we've
got monitors in place for the south of
the borough so if you let us take that
away we will look into that because the
the the the monitor places that we have
here are all looking super yeah on the
surface it looks like they're in the
north of borough so thank you for that
uh counselor Carter
thanks Chad um
before I ask anything I'd just like to
um comment on
how much I'd welcome
um the real large material changes that
are being delivered through some of the
stuff in here particularly looking at um
council tax support schemes uh real
living wage accreditation and free
School meals they're making material
differences to many of our residents
that was the nice bit turned out to um
active travel and again a reflect on
um
I'm hopeful and pleased to see research
showing that people generally want
safe accessible neighborhoods that work
for all modes of transport and it just
makes life better for everybody so my
question is
um
we I think Trafford has experienced some
delays in developing and delivering some
active travel proposals how confident
are you that Council will will improve
on working with stakeholders and funders
to accelerate delivery yeah thank you
for that first of all thank you for your
your first comments on the work that
we've been doing to reduce
or help tackle the causes of poverty as
it happens I managed to attend the uh
part of the closing event of the
Trafford positive truth commission
earlier today and there were some really
good suggestions come out of that that
we'll be building into our our Legacy
site from that so the things that we've
got there are great but there's more
work that we can do around that in terms
of the active travel and that area
um yeah we need to pick up the pace
there and you have my Assurance that I
am meeting with our partners whether it
be Amy whether it be transport for
greater Manchester and have been doing
that since the start of my leadership at
the beginning of the year and I know
that the executive member Aiden Williams
who is another regular at this security
committee um he is also working very
hard to to pick up the Pacer we know
there are twin benefits for us
delivering that first of all is the is
the health benefit and secondly it's the
impact on the environment as well so yes
I I will be very happy to come back in
12 months time and I hope to give a
paint a positive picture of what we've
done in those 12 months
thank you chair
um I have questions on two areas the
first one is on the The Vaping policy
and the second one is on uh domestic
abuse
as an ex-smoker I'm horrified at the
amounts of kids I see walking around
vaping absolutely horrified and I wonder
if there's more we can do to to reduce
the incidence and I'm convinced it's a
gateway to uh smoking a real cigarettes
as we were also to pick up on the point
made by
um councilor Oxford you can't walk
anywhere in Trafford these days without
smelling
cannabis and again I wonder what else we
can do about that particularly against
the normalization of the consumption of
cannabis if you go into my local Town
Center there's a shop there which is
selling
drug paraphernalia in the um in the
windows it's all on display locally now
is the bone shop for obvious reasons I
wonder if there's anything we can we can
do about that sort of there's that
section as well and the second one again
I've applaud the the the
um the refresh of the domestic abuse
policy and I just wondered if there
could be some more detail providers
around what it exactly is that word that
we're doing in terms of uh combat and
domestic abuse thank you chair
thank you um on the the first one yeah I
agree in terms of vaping it is a it is a
step into to to other things I think
whatever we design in terms of looking
at cessation it needs to be
with you know the the people that are
accessing and using it in mind and with
their cooperation because I don't think
and that's not the approach I don't
think just telling people do you we we
have to look at doing it right but I I
completely agree we there's more that we
can do around there and uh yeah again
share your view on the the the pervasive
smell from people smoking cannabis in
the area it is yeah far more common than
it was 10 or so years ago and again it
is something that I particularly dislike
the smell of so it is something that we
can we can factor in
um in terms of the refreshed domestic
abuse policy I'm sure we can get more
information I think Sarah is going to
come in actually at this point so
it's okay with you counselor and Stanley
thank you
so anybody else wishes to speak no okay
counselor watched thank you um
I must confess I didn't know about
traffic data lab until I read the report
I'm ashamed to say
and um I've been on the um Council
website and put traffic data up into the
search engine and nothing's come up I
think so I think suspect there's a lot
of residents out there who don't know
there is
some excellent information in there and
I think a lot of residents would be
interested in I just think for speaking
from personal experience it's something
we should promote more of that to make
it accessible to people put on our
Council web page thank you chair
thank you um I'm glad you've discovered
Trafford data lab now
um it is a really useful resource and
it's been going for years and you're
quite right to pick us up on the website
and not be able to get it through there
we'll look at what we can do but I know
there is you know future proposals
around the website on our you know it
interface um having visited the uh
visited the IT team
um last week and I also was meeting the
the team behind the Trafford days lab
yesterday
um for anyone who hasn't seen it there's
some great work there on the census some
you know shows of paints a picture of
what Trafford looks like now and how
it's changed from 2011 and a lot of work
has been put into putting all that
together and what that will do is help
shape future policy for us so now we
know what that snapshot was back in 2021
and based on other data that comes
through from other sources that is also
on the the day slab it does help us
shape policies for the future and also
look at how best to Future proof our
Council but yeah I hope you enjoy and
get lost in traffic data lab now
just on that could could I recommend
that it becomes part of the councilor's
induction because I suspect most members
won't have visited it thank you
so anybody else wants to speak
if not the thanks for the report of that
I think you know again it's easy easily
easy reading really and and I know it
isn't in in presentation form and I
think that's a good form to have really
rather than Reams and reams of you know
paper quite frankly
um the the thing I wanted to say I I
think there's a lot of really good
things
in there
um and clearly now we need to deliver it
and uh and we are you know started on
that process of delivering it and I
think it's uh really important the
monitoring of the uh kpis really
um and that's something that you know
all councilors should should be aware of
the delivery of of the corporate plan uh
but but thanks very much for uh your
your presentations and answering the
questions are you finished now for the
night I do believe I am so if you don't
mind I'm going to uh if you are a fund
farewell and all being well look forward
to working with you next year some form
or other but enjoy the rest of your uh
your meeting and thank you for all the
support you've given me and the
challenge you've given me over the
course of the year with scrutiny so
thank you very much and have a lovely
evening now thank you very much you you
have been a regular visitor of ours and
uh and very key uh to it to the word
that we do yeah so so thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
right the next item is the accessibility
of council services so is that you Sarah
I'm very happy to introduce this cam
Flor act and thank you very much but I
have brought a friend I've phoned a
friend and uh he will make certainly
present the detail because he is far
closer to it than I am so I'm going to
start first of all by apologizing
because I think we're a little bit tardy
in bringing this back to scrutiny it was
asked for
um a couple of months ago and so my
apologies in the first instance and also
as well just to explain in terms of the
paper that we have sent out the slides
that we've sent out and I'm really
pleased to hear councilor Acton that you
like the refreshed approach to providing
information to scrutiny and we are
presenting you this afternoon uh well
actually it's evening now isn't it and
some information around and contact
through the council's contact center
there are some things that we aren't
able to report upon for example any
inquiries that make their way through
the Amy system and so what you have in
front of you is information relating to
the council's contact center and on that
I will hand over to Simon who will draw
out the Salient points and then we'd be
very happy to take your questions Simon
thank you Simon for coming along
no problem
so yeah I won't go through every detail
on the on the slides that you've already
seen but yeah as Sarah's just said there
are many ways in which people can
contact the council whether that be
direct or
or via
um Amy services in the contact center
there
um and yeah slide there that
details about online email phone
face-to-face channels
the main detail of the report is around
access Trafford contact center which
handles
17 different kind of service areas and
teams
um
mainly by phone there are four email
addresses also handled within that
within that team
aiming to take a customer focused
approach deal with as much as possible
at the first point of contact
there is the list there of the
17 service areas that are taken within
the contact center so
yeah you will see that there are a
number
knots there and therefore those contacts
are being handled
differently often Direct by the team or
the or the service
the performance
kind of slide is very
overview in its base because it was
trying to get kind of pre-pandemic and
and current there as well the key things
to kind of
points out really is actually in 20 2021
um kind of height of kovid
within the access traffic contact center
we saw a significant drop in
telephone contact
um primarily due to our council tax
colleagues not chasing people for money
um which generates quite a lot of
contact
UM
but yeah that was there and as we've
come out of
of covert times and coming back to
whatever normal is now
um you'll notice that the the core
volumes haven't reached what they were
in 1920
but actually our average call length has
increased by I should have made a note
of this I'm now trying to do it in my
head Anna yeah it's about 10 I was doing
the 39 seconds per per course so
actually the total amount of time spent
talking to people is greater than it was
pre
pandemic
um
and yeah some detail there as to why
that and actually is called complexity
that's changed number of different
schemes coming in different sport teams
the team needing to learn what that
means and also confusion amongst
residents as well therefore taking
longer to explain
and other things that add into that
complexity not pandemic related as such
but
we have we have seen increased course
for services that unfortunately the
contact center team can't help with that
that perhaps answers accessible there's
been other things as you will know and
just two of the big ones there being
Ukraine response and needing to be there
for
so that and also cost of living crisis
um causing a number of
of people within the borough to need to
access services that they are not
familiar with and therefore that extra
time
there's some numbers there about emails
but yeah around 7 000 a year
um
a couple of slides in about self-service
so
currently the CRM system is the c360
system that has online portal
that crosses some services that are
delivered by Amy and the one Trafford
contract
and uh
yeah so comments compliments complaints
numbers across both of those
and I miss the the one that I wanted to
focus on and Skip buy was actually the
support for for more vulnerable
residents
um
pull out that actually buy by phone we
are we are doing more to support people
who who need that so
yes completing housing benefit and
council tax support forms within the
within the customer service team
about one person a week blue badge
applications being a lot higher number
of applications being completed with
people over the phone because they're
unable to to do that directly themselves
and the
self-service numbers are there
and then just one slide on the the one
Trafford thing because
the CRM sits within our area we can see
what what is being logged through that
system and this is mainly to demonstrate
that difference between how people are
serving themselves going online and and
accessing self-service and how many are
needing to go via the one Trafford
contact center don't have the detail on
whether they've done that by email phone
letter Etc just know that a person
within one Trafford has
has put that within the system
and then things moving forward so
performances monitored very regularly
within the within our contact center
there is a new CRM being implemented
projects on the way for that
with everything should be live by June
next year so June 24
the services within the contact center
are delivered we meet regularly with
those to make sure that the the front
line service is meeting the needs of the
back office
and
that came up before the ongoing
development Digital support within
libraries to to help people use digital
channels where they're not able
hopefully that was a
good enough overview and yeah any
questions
yeah thanks very much for that overview
uh are there any questions at councilor
Walsh first thanks
um
CRM system I think um one of my fellow
councils is described as being clunky
and I use it quite a lot and it it is
quite a frustrating system to use
um
I'm just think you know looking I know
we were gonna we plan to update him
surprise it's going to be June 24. are
there any there isn't any quick fixes we
could do to kind of streamline it um
unfortunately not the current system
that we have is is actually
past its support period so it is no
longer being developed by the supplier
the move to Dynamics 365 the the June 24
is the the aim when everything will have
moved so
I'm certainly hoping that there will be
some of those
services that will move before that so
that we can see
some benefits
yeah I just think if you know I have to
say if we had a better system I think we
might have more more customers using I
think there's a lot of frustration if
you for example if you put an address in
you put an address in it and then you
decide it's the wrong address the system
kind of freezes you've got to go away
and come back again and can see
residents getting frustrated with that
thank you
okay I'll move along the line yeah okay
thanks chair
um just in terms of the the telephone
calls received there's been an increase
in calls which are not for the contact
center
which seems to imply there's a bit of a
information Gap somewhere somewhere in
there that people are not getting the
right contacts is there any way we can
try and reduce that because obviously
that if you could resolve that problem
you'd be able to deal with actual the
real cause quickly and deal with those
faster as those times will go down
so is there any way you can do that
there used to be like a paper directory
a little booklet I'm not suggesting we
do that and it's these days but
something like that to try and get the
information out there that's obviously
missing something
um yeah I think there's a there's a few
things there I think the way that the
contact center Has Come Together
historically in the services that
combine to make this this contact center
is there
there are obviously challenges amongst
the number of teams within the within
the council the
yeah I sit in the contact center at
least
twice a week and will regularly overhear
people saying you really need to speak
to I will attempt to put you through
this is the number you need
um and for whatever reason they are
unable to do that and therefore will
ring the the kind of the the big 2000
number that that comes in and people
Express their dissatisfaction that way
um so yeah there's
potential improvements that could be
made it's then
actually what are we
yeah how many of those do we want to
move to a digital channel how many of
those is it capacity within teams as
well I don't know Sarah's looking at me
I don't know if she's got anything to
add to that I
yeah and thank you and I I do think that
um in terms of the upgrade of CRM but
also as well the upgrade that's required
around telephony systems and we're
starting to see those things Collide at
the moment and we know that we do have a
plan for that
um and we just need to
um gather some pieces of momentum behind
that plan so that we can address some of
these issues counselor Proctor but to
give you an assurance
it's not something that we're not aware
of and it is something that's very very
high on the agenda thank you
councilor win Stanley
uh thank you chair Castle Proctors and
asked the first part of the question I
was going to myself thank you councilman
the um the question really is around the
Improvement plan for the for the call
handling data because the call handling
data is interpret on that screen is not
great is it it's
um
you've got I assume I'm reading this
correctly answered only 63 percent adds
with 30 seconds 43 percent
watch what is our Target in the areas in
the in the table
it doesn't seem great unless I'm
misreading the um misreading table and
if I am correct and I'm reading the
table correctly what is the what is the
Improvement plan because it comes a lot
it comes up a lot on the doorstep that
we tried to ruin the council we don't
get anywhere yeah yeah we don't get
anywhere yeah so within the
so this is the
the course that we can measure because
they're coming through the core Center
um telephony system the the aims we aim
to answer 95 of course and 70 of those
within 30 seconds and you're absolutely
right we're not close to that
the
the aims to improve that are about
trying to encourage as many people to
use a digital channel as they can so
that then the
the team are there to help the people
who can't so the you know we're there
for the people who need it to be
the that answered percentage
um is always a
a challenging one because small changes
we'll see
big improvements
um
in that people don't just try once
so if you've
you've got it and and that's in that's
an impossible thing to measure if
someone's really got a problem let's
pick on their council tax bill they
really need to talk to us if they run
out of time and hang up once they will
try again so um that's not an excuse
um
more annoyed and it will take longer
yes no no I'm not yeah I'm not
disagreeing with the your assessment of
those
of those numbers that
the reality is that
there aren't enough people there to be
able to to cope with it it's
that's the
that's the the where we are we will we
do regularly work with the team to
to Target how effectively that they're
that calls are being dealt with and
doing that in the the best way that it's
possible whilst also recognizing that we
that we need to handle as many of those
contacts
first time rather than quickly and then
causing future contacts so
yeah sorry that's not very clear and
it's a sort of it's it almost generates
extra work and I understand the resource
issue I do when I understand trying to
get people onto
um
electronic ways of raising the issues
with you but what happens when residents
don't go through to you is
all of us here our phones just start to
ring and then your phones your phone
starts to ring
so I'm just I'm just trying to
what what what what do we say to people
on the doorstep when they say we cannot
get through to the council I think
something
um else just about
that and it has been um alluded to
during the conversation if you look at
the average core length that is going
off and that's
sort of Testament to the complexity of
some of the calls that we're receiving
so
um the people that we are speaking to
we're spending quality time with we're
trying to resolve issues at that phase
points of contact
UM
we absolutely would want to speak to
every single person that calls the
contact center for
lots of reasons that's not happening at
the moment we are absolutely on to that
we are working through what the
solutions may be
totally get the the situation you're in
and I suppose
um if there's any Assurance we can give
you it is when people do get through we
are spending the time with them to work
through any issues that they may have as
you can see from the average core length
and the time that we are spending with
people who make through to the contact
center
[Music]
the only answer we can get to people
that is to either come through us
or go electronically by email basically
or the CRM system or to call the contact
center but it may be that it just takes
that little bit longer to get through
thank you
counselor Carter
thank you my questions uh relate to the
Amy contact center and Amy's responses
to uh customers and residents so two
questions really one do you think their
service is good
and two and this is really really
specific and relates to potholes funnily
enough
I have had residents contact me saying
I've reported a pothole and here's the
answer and the answer is something along
the lines of the issue does not meet the
criteria's effer intervention
it possibly fewer words in that
and if I was a resident who'd gone to
the F reporting something got that as an
answer I would be absolutely fuming and
I get residents who are so overall what
do you think of their service and B can
that answer be made to something that's
more human please
thank you councilor Carter I think I
want to put Simon in a position to have
to answer the question around his view
on the Amy contact center because he's
not a customer of the Amy contact center
and I do think that's something that we
can take away and we can pick up a
conversation with our colleagues at Amy
to understand
their response rates and how
um they respond to um contact through
the contact center but if it's okay with
you I'm not sure it's appropriate for
Simon to comment on his view of Amy on
the basis that he wouldn't have the same
level of contact as your residents would
have cherry you happy with well I I
think
um
the the fact is that
um you know there's waste and recycling
highways street cleaning parks and Open
Spaces that seem to be
seem to be distant from Trafford as a
whole and I think that's the point that
councilor Carter is getting out and how
how do we kind of monitor
you know those services and how how the
responses
um
I know Steve is wanting to uh yeah uh
obviously uh this is part of the Amy
side contract although it actually does
go through uh the CRM system and they
are quite linked up her I've cut I've
lost track of the amount of times I've
taken up those sort of similar points
that uh councilor cars has actually made
to say uh it's every prompt and I think
we're in the current system it's very
limited to what we changes they could
make to it so frustration I share those
frustrations so much so I think as part
of the new system coming in it is going
to be much more aligned to give much
more human responses but I certainly uh
when people uh counselors and others
draw these to my attention I always
discuss them with Richard Chris on
others and Sharon and and but they are
very much aware this lights will show
you and it's something that and it
plagues them there much as much as it
plagues me and we're trying to make it
that bit more human but we're in this
system as as the bodyman said positions
out of date now and it is being replaced
and it is very limited to actually how
much it can be changed but certainly
I'll take that back up with Richard
again and say if we can make any further
changes to it in interim until the new
system comes online but I share
everyone's frustration on this it is an
absolute uh it's it does not come across
well and I've sent numerous examples to
people uh to officers and and we all
share the frustrations with it so it's
something I will raise it again with us
to see if we can have any change in the
interim I know thanks very much for all
those answers uh just to be clear I
wasn't saying I think their service is
poor I'm saying I don't know I was
asking what do you think of yourself
something that really asked them to uh
comment back on in writing the specific
minor point that I was making about is
then human answer I'm completely relaxed
about the being a a stock cut and paste
automated answer it's just that the
words used
uh
insulting
um so if that can be addressed please
but I think I think there is that wider
point though we we don't know how how
they respond in terms of the the
timelines of calls and whether they get
through all of those kind of things we
don't seem to understand you know what
is happening and somebody must know they
must have
um themselves they must
you know monitor those kinds of issues
so we should know as a council
um what well they are so even if we
don't like it we we need to know I think
anyway councilor Faz
yeah thank you so
um my sort of I've got two points I'd
like to make perhaps that's a more
accurate way of expressing this on the
first the first one's a question on the
inbound calls
um the licensing department is not
listed in one of those bullet points
unless it's subsumed within something
else so I'd like to know if those
numbers are reflected on the previous
table
I Echo things from both sides of this
um yes those numbers are not good 66
means sorry 63 means more than a third
of calls are not answered
um and I have worked in such places in
my youth so I know what it's like with
all these figures and trying to meet the
hit the button
um so I'd like to know if licensing is
included
um and the reason I asked that is I just
wanna I think I and from your side I
share the frustration that obviously
it's literally a resourcing issue
um so I understand that nevertheless I
think it would be prudent perhaps for
speaking truth to power to actually hear
what some of the residents say
so you know a typical email I might get
and I will I've sort of anonymized this
but uh thank you so much for the trouble
you've taken trying to sort out contact
with Trafford I was given four numbers
to try hidden Department one with an
answer phone where you could leave a
message they promised to respond within
three to five days not exactly a speedy
response I've left three messages now
two weeks ago with no kind of response
the other three were answered with the
message that the person couldn't take
your call you cannot leave a message
I've been trying these for a couple of
days now uh it feels to me like no one
has any intention of answering I will
persist in trying to get hold of someone
in Department X as it's now my
lifetime's ambition to make contact with
this mysterious Department other than
logging a complaint through you
counselor
um about this please don't spend any
more time on this as I'm sure you've got
more important things to do that is a
typical email that I get and I think I
appreciate their concerns and I
appreciate the pressures nonetheless I
want to represent them
so I totally
um
accept and appreciate and respect the
fact that you want to represent a
residents and what would be really
helpful counselor fast is absolutely
we've got
um we are we are webcasting so it would
be helpful if maybe you could share that
with me and I will take that up
um internally within the council because
we don't want that kind of response
going to Residents and and it's
deeply frustrating I I imagine so
absolutely uh you know deeply
frustrating so please do send that on
and um I will do whatever I can to
unblock that thank you
licensing on that explicitly counted
within those numbers there will be some
calls that come through to the contact
center trying to get hold of Licensing
unfortunately the team there
are not skilled or equipped and the
inbound calls for licensing are handled
by that team and service
I just want to
it's a bit concerning perhaps if we're
worried that 63 one of my colleagues
read out is not satisfactory if we add
Licensing in I'm I'm worried that that
figures can go down even more so it may
be worse than we think I don't know if
others want to reflect on that
counselor Oxford
um yeah I'm gonna put my positive note
the times I have called
on behalf of residence I've got through
straight away and had a really good
responses and I haven't had any
residents complaining to me about not
being able to get through so so you know
the response is obviously varies um I
just wondered about web chat is that
something you've you could offer because
that's a really good way of people
connecting with you and
it's it's definitely a channel and I
think we need to make sure that we've
got the right digital offer to be able
to do that
um
yeah certainly a
just just on that Council of Oxford we
are we do have the ability now to shape
some of the response for the new systems
and mostly on the web chat and chat Bots
are are as a part of that
um consideration for what we need
because I totally agree and myself I use
a web chat quite a bit when I'm trying
to resolve issues so we will make sure
that that's part of the scoping thank
you that's really good because I used to
do advice work as well and I used to use
use web check myself for various
organizations and it's just such a
speedy way of getting responses thank
you
can I ask about the welfare rights
officers
how many have we got them are they
coping during this cost of living crisis
um I can't tell you how many we've got
what I can tell you is that demand has
increased so where they were
experiencing I think at the last meeting
we had
um as as some of you will know we have a
cost of living focus and group and at
the last meeting that we had called had
gone up from an average of around 62 a
week to just over 100 it was 101 a week
so demand for that service is increasing
and I will come back to you with the
number of Staff within that team thanks
counselor
can I just ask how many people or
percentage of the workforce within that
customer service side are working from
home
uh
still and
do they when they do do they have the
full facilities of being able to respond
uh is that likely to have some kind of
impact on this performance in the in the
sense of being able to respond in the
Fuller manner if they were in the office
so to speak thank you yes so the the
contact center within my area there is a
mix of people working in the office or
at home
can't remember the exact proportion it's
probably about a quarter of people are
at home and three quarters in the office
as an estimate
um and when at home yes they have
exactly the same facilities as if they
were in the office and the the
monitoring and the performance
measurement capabilities are exactly the
same as if they were in the office
um
um well thanks thanks very much Simon
and Sarah I know there's a lot of issues
there really and
um
I I think as members have said you know
there is some dissatisfaction out there
but I think you recognize that and
trying to
um overcome it with the new systems and
so on so thanks very much for
for attending tonight and presenting to
us and answering the questions
yes oh definitely yes yes
foreign
[Laughter]
yeah say say no more about that
yeah thank you
right
um
we're now on item eight and it's a gypsy
Roma and travelers visit report now this
has gone has actually been to the
executive the report was received really
well
and I think
one of the features of the
recommendation was to try to
establish a stopping place for the
Gypsies and travelers and
um I think rather than go through all
the report because it's been through
this committing it was approved by this
committee
um and I think
just at that point around when I
attended the executive uh to to speak
about the report it
there was a lot of compliments around
the task and finish group
um and around the recommendations and I
think you know the
um it was a good response
from the executive in terms of the
actions that
um you know they they uh trying to
implement at this moment in time so I
think if we could talk about what was
proposed by the executive in terms of a
temporary stopping place that would be a
good starter really thank you yeah I'll
just introduce and then hand over to a
Adrian obviously uh I share the
responsibility with James now uh during
covid when a lot of the pumps come out
I've covered it exclusively so I was
very familiar with what the problems and
uh I I've seen the frustrations across
the borough uh when people when they
were using a lot of the uh encampments
with the legal ones as they'll call I
think her across the brother and a lot
of the problems they generated so I
think it's come quite clear to us at
that point there we did need something
uh which as I identified really
obviously in the longer run we're going
to be looking at a permanent site with
Pub facilities and that's and that will
be a part of the local plan that you I'm
sure you're all familiar with but
however that's by the time we get down
to be some time away and gets so we
thought it's quite reasonable obviously
for yourselves and everything that we
actually look to provide some sort of
sight there and officers look very
diligently across the borough for a sort
of temporary stopping type for the next
few years
and eventually we've come up with the
one just up the road from here and I
believe that that is being discussed to
some extent with the uh the Roman Gypsy
traveler communities I'm not personally
sure how that's being done but officers
are looking at that as well and we're
from we last discussed this as well I
know I think one of the questions to
Executive was that uh they believed at
times the site may have been used for
illegal match parking and and officers
have taken that away and that is also
being looked at as part of this there so
I think uh it's obviously in a good
position now where we can actually move
forward with this I'll obviously welcome
uh particularly any comments that are
not Adrian wants to add anything
I I think what we'd probably like to
know is
what the progress is in terms of
is it Boyer Street
um yeah yes certainly thank you chair I
think that um thank you councilor
outside
um yeah so uh as we've heard
um we undertook
um uh a site investigation process we
also conferred and with
um and had a look at some of the
experiences elsewhere uh as I think the
report alludes to
um and I have to say in this regard
um you know it's probably a bit more
challenging in the context that we have
in Trafford because as you know we're
very urbanized Authority and you know
land is very intensively used so
um you know even some of the other
metropolitan areas where this has been
used successfully
um have a bit more sort of Hinterland if
you like than than we do
um but having gone through that process
we we identified uh boa Street as a
possible option
um and
um as the exact exec report authorized
um that has been the subject of of
consultation
um so
um we have consulted with
um directly with
um businesses and
um residents uh within the vicinity of
that site
um so we we kind of Drew effectively a
red line around uh the general area and
and sent out letters to to those
addresses we use the usual uh social
media and other means of of publicizing
this
um and we also um identified a series of
groups that represent
um uh gypsies Roma and traveling people
as well
um uh there isn't a sort of universal
group that we've been able to identify
that is specific to uh greater
Manchester
um but but there are some locally based
ones that particularly look at
um at Irish traveling Community
um so we've gone to them but also there
are various other travel
um
um gypsy Roman traveler Charities and
umbrella organizers Asians elsewhere and
of course bearing in mind that the
people who will use uh this site
um are almost certainly going to be
based somewhere else in the country
um because you know they will be passing
through this area
um you know as part of their their their
seasonal Journeys so actually almost in
a way they the people we need to speak
to perhaps they're not local they are
further afield so anyway we've
identified a series of groups and we
consulted on them and the stage we're
now at is that that consultation has
just closed
um we know that um we've had a decent
response so about 400 responses
um
um so we're looking at those to see
there may well be duplicates within that
um so we're just starting the process of
of interrogating all of that seeing
um you know too early I'm afraid to say
uh what what
um you know what people have commented
on
um because it has literally just closed
um but um obviously that's the stage
we're at we'll now drill into all of
that
um the executive report did
delegate some some of the decisions
around this but obviously we will confer
very closely with the relevant portfolio
holders as Council officers and of
course take account of any further
comments that this committee may have
um and really I think until we've been
through that process of analysis it's
probably a little bit early to say quite
what the next step is but anyway that's
where we are and hopefully
um it's it's moving forward thank you
chair thank you for that do any
questions yeah councilor Oxford
sorry I just got a few there
so um I wondered how how they're going
to be made aware of this site and I know
you've spoke already about how you've
made some consultations and I know that
many of them do prefer rural areas so I
wondered how we can attract them to go
to this kind of quite a narrow it looks
like quite a narrow road and I wondered
how safe that was for children and
whether you're going to be able to
provide water which I think is another
issue isn't it I also wanted to check it
says in the survey it said um they can
stay for two to three weeks understand
that 28 days is the maximum
they can stay is that correct yeah and
what would happen after that
um because then it would involve
enforcement costs again I assume
um and I just wonder with friends
families and travelers were consulted
like the group that we originally
um spoke to
um yeah they were the main questions
thank you
yeah thank you chair um we'll start with
the the simple one so yes friends
families and travelers were
um consulted so they were one of the
groups um identified
um uh in terms of how this will work
um uh obviously I think that's you know
if it is confirmed that this site is
suitable
um then we will then going to have to
devise a protocol around how we we
persuade people to use it and I think in
a way it is about saying well
um and this is this is what we've
learned from liaising with with certain
other places is it's very much about
building a relationship with people to
say well you know it depends where they
are but often they're in places where
you know there may be an existing use
that's being interrupted and to be able
to save them will look it's not a great
place for you to stay here but there is
a safe place we'll provide blade toilets
will provide bins Etc
um and you know we will just have to see
whether it is something that is in in
practice is is of Interest
um as regards water
um I think that's a really good point
because actually
um as the committee will probably know
that the health determinants of uh and
health outcomes of many um nomadic
peoples is
um considerably worse than the settled
population and part of that is sometimes
around access to Safe Water
um and now that's a little bit tricky in
some respects because you know how do
you provide that how do you manage that
um but certainly that is
um that's something that we are Keen to
explore I can't make any promises around
it but certainly
um we're very mindful of the need
um for for better water
um and I think finally
um as regards to the the safety of the
site
um it is it is a fairly quiet cul-de-sac
um but at the moment it is open at
either end
um I think we would be in difficulty in
completely closing it off because
there'd be all sorts of issues about
rights of way and so on
um but that may well be one of those
sort of practical considerations that
um we we will need to think about
um but to be honest that will often
apply in other locations as well so it
is I should stress you know if it is
confirmed that we should proceed with
this site I think it's fair to say there
are a number of practical considerations
that we'll need to assess so can I just
just add while you're looking at it as
well but I can't say Obviously is that
when we're looking at more permanent
sites in which is in local plan
certainly water and that little feature
in that's just obviously much more
difficult in what's a temporary site to
do but certainly something that's been
looked at as Adrian said yeah I mean I
really appreciate that you know the end
of the day it gives them summer to stay
and that's that that's really good I
just wanted to ask good about that for
28 is that 28 days is that the longest
they can stay there
well I suppose that might be one of the
one of the things that comes through the
consultation process as to what the
right length of stays but but there's a
clearly the balance
um
um I mean people are normally passing
through they will stay for a period
naturally
um and then move on so finding the right
period is perhaps again you know one of
those things we'll we'll need to think
about
um but
um you know that seems to be it's of
that order again that's what we've
gleaned from elsewhere so so you can
make the decision about that absolutely
that's not necessarily fixed and I would
anticipate that we may well get comments
about that through the consultation
process
councilor Carter
thank you um three questions for me
um first of all
looking back at the last couple of
Summers where there have been incidents
of
um unauthorized stops do you know how
many vehicles people were involved in
those and is the capacity of the
proposed site big enough to take that
volume of people
uh secondly and now the consultation is
just finished but do you have any flavor
of the sensitive response from the
representatives of the GRT Community
um to that site in particular I'm
pointing because it's it's almost
adjacent and it's got some very
distinctive characteristics including
I'll play the grass the quarter of a
mile
um
and thirdly just
thinking out loud it's adjacent to a
derelict GMP building which must have a
water supply is have we looked at the
option of getting a water supply via
there thank you
okay
um so in terms of the
um have we got a flavor
um uh then no um I'm sorry we literally
just
um got got the a sense of the numbers so
you know that's that's as far as we go
um in terms of the um capacity
clearly that that does vary it varies
from group to group
um but
um you know it's it's often about half a
dozen vehicles of that sort of order
um maybe a few more so we think it is
probably uh sufficient for most purposes
um
um and then I think with regards to
water it yes absolutely that's a good
point in that well I think what we'll do
is take that away
um we'll obviously have to think about
how you know how that's paid for how
that's arranged
um and how close it is but certainly if
it's confirmed for by Street then it's
worthy of expiration absolutely
okay yeah counselor
thank you
I suppose the burden of servicing the
facilities the cost will fall on the
council taxpayer
and uh
the consultation just seems to have been
done with the people that are going to
use the facilities what about the the
consultation for the people residents
you know sort of being able to be
consulted who are actually going to be
paying for the facilities and the second
question is is there likely to be for
people perhaps who might stay for the
full 28 days or whatever you decide
uh any cost put on them or invited to
pay for using the facilities thank you
yeah well I think in terms of the
consultation obviously we we
um we've identified I suppose there's
sort of three groups we're aiming at
this with the immediate residents and
businesses there were the specialist
um organizations if I can call them that
and then you know the public at large
because we've obviously publicized it
through our usual channels I guess when
we analyze things we'll understand where
people are commenting from
um uh but but certainly we weren't
looking just exclusively at local people
we did want to get that wider view
because of course it's the whole of
Trafford who tend to experience uh
encampments um uh in terms of the cost
yes it absolutely does fall on on the
taxpayer but there are costs of course
at the moment to the taxpayer as set out
in the report so you know we are paying
for cleanup we are paying for
um bailiffs where it's appropriate to
use those and of course we're paying for
Council time as well the The Experience
elsewhere tends to be that suggests that
um you know it's either a kind of break
even in other words doing this is no
more expensive
uh in some cases I think particularly in
leads they estimated save the money I
think that would be I I probably
hesitate to put any too much ambition
around that
um but but certainly that's what leads
leads seem to be suggesting
um so we're already experiencing costs
and I suppose what this will do is
perhaps
use those costs in a different way
hopefully to better Mutual outcome
um and um
yes I think that's probably that's
that's the objective of Sydney thank you
yeah
um I think in the report it says in
terms of the consultation any temporary
stopping facility would need to be the
subjective local consultation so added
in the report you just add Chef uh to
council but sir comments there partly
other problem we've got of course as
well I think Adrian's obviously covered
that they have existing companies uh
legal ones but I think part of the
problem with those is that a lot of
inconvenience it's called to local
residents in some cases it's been quite
yeah and I've seen in School principles
myself where it's been dangerous where
they're getting novel footways through
parks with uh if you've been shoved out
the way while Caravans are going through
these never pass through Parks so I
think putting a dedicated site will help
with that I've also I'm aware that
certainly at least two maybe three local
community events that that's been
canceled during the few years where
where those encampments take place and
it meant that one day I think one of
them Ward was a sporting day for
youngsters on a Saturday morning and
that had to be canceled because
obviously it wasn't possible so I think
by providing this site we've had a
dedicated facility that actually should
actually help to avoid all sort of
problems that we've got now uh certain
thing as Adrian has said that that
actually happened now a lot of the
problems we've got now so providing the
facilities it will actually enable us to
actually help those communities to
actually carry on with their day-to-day
stuff and providing dedicated facilities
obviously we've got work to do in making
sure uh and involving how it will work
but I think certainly having a proper
dedicated app will actually help our
local communities to actually be able to
uh get on with the event's not put a lot
the inconvenience that they've actually
had over the last few years but I think
it's something that we all support here
I think there's there's been no one
suggesting that we shouldn't be doing I
think it's the right thing to do thank
you
thank you can I just briefly comment on
that last point I think is well we have
to remember that the cancer is not
funded purely by council tax from people
in Trafford a huge amount for our
funding comes from national government
and of course the Gypsy Roman traveler
Community are contributing to our our
national tax they'll be paying their vat
they'll be paying their income tax and
so on so I I don't think yes yes even
people who maybe live in a different
country and have come here
um will still be paying VAT on anything
they spend here and so on so we this is
a group of people who are contributing
in lots of different ways not just
financially and we shouldn't just look
at it as a burden really no I'm just
trying to say this it's a local issue
the government doesn't the government
doesn't pay for everything that's done
locally okay
okay
is there any other questions no
um well thank thanks for
coming tonight you know I think it's
obviously something that we've the the
committee has been interested in and I
think progress has has actually been
made
um I think that
um
the
what was I going to say now
um
yeah I I I think what what we probably
need need to do is to
see the response from the consultation
that you've you know either then now and
um you know whether you could circulate
um you know the findings of the
consultation just in simple forms really
uh because obviously there'll be a lot
of repeat stuff
within the consultation so that I think
that would help us
um to to understand what what
um you know
the the people that would be likely to
come
to to to Trafford to that
um provision uh our feeling and thinking
about that and and that will be helpful
for us to sort of analyze it
um but but thanks very much for coming
tonight it's much appreciated
okay
um thank you chair thank you yeah I know
that thanks very much we moved to
um item nine and it's items for
consideration
uh
in the next Municipal year
um
you know what we can consider if if
there's any items that we want to uh
scrutinize in that coming year
um I mean we don't need to do it now but
if anybody's got any ideas it can just
filter in
um and uh obviously you know it'll be a
new committee
um after the all-out elections so you
know we we it would just be suggestions
at this moment in time it's not a
definite if we you know if we do suggest
something
so have we got anything yeah Council
Winston uh yeah that'd be quite
interesting to have the um the team back
who talked about response times to see
how they were changing as we go into the
next in the next year
uh the team who presented on the
response times to Residence inquiries
would be really Keen to have them back
obviously
probably a quarter in to the next the
next year when they've been some
progress mode yeah
yeah I think there's enough concerns
around that area that uh
just just on that point chair if that
was the case could they bring their Amy
colleagues with them
yeah yeah
obviously we would need that wouldn't we
because we we've not got much
information around the account Council
of Faz
thank you yeah I Deco that actually was
a really good idea it's a lot to follow
up on that
um I'd just like to know if the scrutiny
committee thinks we ought to investigate
the level of action being taken around
dampen mold that might be something we
should look at there's all sorts of
mechanisms aren't there Housing Act 2004
Environmental Protection 1990 statutory
nuisances there's new bills before
Parliament at the moment around social
housing regulation in November just gone
the secretary of state has directed all
Council leaders including councilor Ross
under section three of the Housing Act
to ensure that all providers are
conducting rapid remedial Works should
scrutiny have some oversight of of maybe
what's going on there have some sort of
facts and figures on that well
I was actually going to suggest that uh
I've already already spoken to counselor
Ross about it and he thinks that it
would be a
a good idea
um
I mean I've been dealing with people
who've got mold in the property
so and it would be very very useful for
the
housing associations to you know present
to us
um so I think I think obviously it is a
suggestion at this moment in time but of
course you know I think it would be
something that we would all be
interested in we they'll what they
should feel they're having their feet
held to the fire and I think everyone
around here would absolutely agree with
that and um and we have been directed by
government to to do something so we
ought to yeah um you know we must take
it seriously yeah absolutely Council
Winston yeah just to follow up on the
point about having the team back in
terms of the response time there's one
other item which was which it would be
great just for the person of the minute
to include when they come back next time
is what was missing from the reports
apart from Amy was the One-Stop shop out
in sale which is the way that disabled
people get access to occupational
therapists and adaptations and all the
rest of it and I've not seen data on
that for quite a while I'd be interested
that was added to the performance data
when the next time they come back before
they before the community say thank you
Chad yep that's a good suggestion can I
just bring uh Council Oxford in um yeah
I thought I'd be interested in
um social housing providers like um
travel house and Trust
um what they're doing around
retrofitting
I did we went to Ritalin really
interesting presentation about that so I
think it'd be really good too I didn't
capture that part of it oh like Trafford
Housing Trust and other um social
housing providers what they're doing
around retrofitting right
uh yeah councilor Walsh thanks chair I'm
interested in
um
we are we're all interested in community
groups I'm interested in what the
community groups feel about our Parks
our friends of parks groups
um
I'd like to know what what their
feelings are about the service we're
providing in our parks in order that's
if that's possible to screw no there's a
regular meeting with the parks but uh
I'd be interested in groups coming to
see us and talking about their
experiences
within that service
yeah well it's a suggestion
okay is there any a bit oh so sorry I
presume chair at this stage this is
chucking things into the hopper it is
it's interesting just I have a
suggestion but just uh following up on
uh councilor Wall shoes if we were to
look at what people think about Parks I
would hope that we could um involve
people not just but also beyond the
constituted Parts groups
um to get a broader view
um the
the thought I have for adding to the
hopper is around
Housing Development and
bringing on building of new houses there
is a long-established national and local
principle of Brownfield first I think it
might be interesting to understand
um
how Trafford council is approaching that
and demonstrating that commitment
pipeline of planning applications and
potential plan implications and
um see yeah have every have all the
Brownfield site opportunities uh being
considered thanks yeah
I think clearly we've we've got two task
and finish groups that are in the
process of working on
um Bond Man United and
um the the other is
and the reduction
of car usage basically
um and that's going to carry you know
those two are going to carry over so
we've got to just spare that in in mind
as well
we're more or less at the end of the
municipal year now so
um
yeah
well we've made a note of that you know
we we we're not sure who's going to be
on the committee because that has to be
decided through the AGM of the council
so
um so it is just suggestions and I think
that you know the reasonable suggestions
to me
so okay so
can we move on which I think we've
practically finished now
um yeah
urgent business I don't have any
so that does conclude the meeting and
can I thank you all for your attendance
and your contributions which as always
are very good
[Music]
thank you all for the last Municipal
year this last Municipal year and uh you
know all your help and support
which has been appreciated
okay then we'll have a good journey at
home
[Music]